good morning bachelor nation welcome to
roses and roses a live I am Lauren Zima
and I am here with wills will he be the
bachelor that's the question we're about
to talk about wills how are you doing
great how are you I'm so great I'm so
happy that you're here you guys this is
wills first interview ever about the
show and he was just eliminated in what
I would call literally the most
heart-wrenching moment of the season so
far last night so he's processing that
and of course we want to know what you
guys have to say to wills what questions
you have for him is to leave them on our
social platforms I will get them here on
our iPad but we're gonna dive right in
because I have a whole slew of things to
discuss with you the first though is the
fact that you guys I want you to look at
this man's outfit I knew he would turn
it up here today and what we have
discovered is he put this together
himself he didn't buy these new pants
and the shirt together they just went
tell me how you come to this conclusion
about these pants I really like these
pants and I've tried the morning and
immediately fell in love with them about
maybe six months ago and then I was at a
different store maybe about two months
ago and I saw this shirt and the
patterns like almost exactly the same
and I was like I have to get it well I
don't it looks like you bought them
together then he tells me well I have a
blazer that also goes but I haven't
gotten it tailored yet is that one of
your secrets are you a guy who'd get
stuff tailored I mean before I never got
things tailor but now I feel like if
you're gonna have a seat especially I
think I'm pretty sure I'm done growing
now I think I'm done growing but now
it's like if you have a suit like you
should put money into it and invest in
it because you're gonna have it for a
long time so you want it to fit well I
mean you are by far if not the most ever
one of the most stylish contestants ever
on the show we were just saying maybe
you and diggie Moreland's up there but
like you looked good this season last
night you worked everything from a
leopard print collared shirt to a floral
sleeveless top - I think you what was
that print that you got sent home yeah
my buddy's like to call them wing suits
and the thing that are like short sleeve
button up collared shirts that have
crazy pattern it's kind of Hawaiian
esque but this one had like kind of
different like kind of almost Paisley I
don't know I was in the Bahamas I was
feeling kind of tropical you know you
know with the floral so I had a
different kind of pattern
okay and you didn't know that you were
going to become known as like the most
stylish girl at all this is a surprise
to normally wear okay and when you're
packing for the show do they tell you
bring stuff for a tropical environment
no they did not actually I bought that
shirt on the road yeah but no I just
kind of pack for every eventuality and
you know I wanted some casual clothes
but I also wanted some clothes to
impress and it's kind of like I kind of
call it like when you pack for Vegas you
know when you pack for Vegas every time
you step outside the hotel room you're
just impressed so when I packed I wanted
to pack with every single outfit
something to impress Wow so this is how
wills approach this season you guys I
didn't know that you got to shop a
little bit during the season yeah you
were like I need to okay so let's talk
about this exit wills I want to read to
you I want to read to you some tweets
wills please don't cry stop filming
someone get him a hug
me watching wills cry and thinking girl
he is top-three material nah F that girl
he's husband material he had to get out
of the car to cry I'm crying too wills
wills please don't cry i 100% date you
wills no baby if you need a shoulder to
cry on I am here for you and Becca I'm
coming for you for making wills cry over
a guy who wasn't even falling in love
with you
so you cried as Becca was sending you
home as she was telling you goodbye yeah
then you cried in the car actually I
didn't cry when she sent me home I was
just trying to process everything it was
a shock to me I did not think I was
gonna go home I thought I was good to go
I did everything that I wanted to do up
to that point when she sent me home my
wall kind of melee came back up and in
my exit interview I was just very very
upset trying to process everything and
then once I got out of the car that's
kind of when all the tears flow I mean
you told them pull over the car yeah I
was ready to get out because because I
wanted even though I know I don't have
any personal time I wanted to get out of
the car and just kind of let everything
out it's been a long journey a lot of
emotions a lot of intensity a lot of you
know effort and it kind of came to an
end abruptly and I just needed to let it
out
so why do you say pull over the cars
because there are still producers in the
car with you and you needed a total I
just I mean I was in a confined space I
wanted some air I just
wanted to kind of be with myself for a
second and just let it all out so how
long is that car ride how long are you
in tears about oh man to be honest that
car ride felt like forever I think
that's part of the reason I just wanted
to get out but I mean my mind was all
over the place at that time I didn't
really know well I got sent home I was
kind of questioning myself a lot I just
I don't know I just really just kind of
wanted to run away screaming a little
bit but he know I tried to compose
myself and you know I wasn't really
upset at Beca I just upset the situation
well let's talk about your surprise
though because and tell me you know if
I'm right or wrong in this book with Leo
that relationship felt very new to me I
was not surprised that she sent Leo home
and then it gets down to you know Colton
Blake Garrett already have roses it's
you and Jason
so you're thinking no she and I are
connected there's no way through Jason
and no this is no detriment to Jason I
love Jason Jason when my closest friends
in the house I just personally felt like
my connection with her was very very
strong and every conversation we had the
whole day it was very very powerful we
talked about family are familiar
similarities and everything and I just
felt like she was ready to come home
and she wasn't so I just had to deal
with that in a very abrupt time and it
was difficult what did that feel like
devastating kind of felt like a huge
just like rock just like just fell into
your gut and you're just I don't know
like all those all those doubts you have
in your mind you try to push back they
all come back out like very quickly and
it just it's a lot of pain and you just
have to deal with it the best way you
can I feel like you're getting your like
biting your lip a little bit I feel like
you're getting mean this is this all
happen and then watch it again last
night it was just like this kind of
brings back bad memories but you know
I'm glad I went through it and
everything like I told her I can't
remember exactly when but everything I
go through is gonna lead me to her so
this is just another chapter and leading
me dark who's her my wife future wife
wherever she is what was it like to
watch it back last night um to be honest
every time I watch myself I'm very proud
um I left everything out there that I
you know I wanted to do I told her
exactly how I felt when I felt it and
she just decided that I wasn't the one
for her and I can't
do you feel like you want more answers
on that I mean mental all will happen
how are you feeling to be honest I don't
really I kind of I don't really want to
live in the past anymore watching this
all this back I've been living in the
past for a while I told her that night
as long as she's happy I'm happy
I don't really need any more answers she
kind of showed me how she felt and
that's fine and as long as she's happy
with one of my best friends whoever they
may be I'm good to go but like you said
you're so surprised and I don't remember
I mean I'm you know I was watching and I
was very wrapped up in it I don't
remember the exact answer she gave you
why did you feel like she told me that
she just didn't feel like she could get
there on the eve of going to see
families and that's pretty much her only
explanation it didn't seem very in-depth
to me but I didn't mean if she doesn't
feel like she doesn't feel that way I
don't need to keep digging especially
now so there's not part of you that's
wondering but why you know she doesn't
want to be with me that's fine as long
as she's happy and she's finding her
person that's why we well we're getting
comments Barbie saying wills you are
fire there's so many people including
Rita so many others saying wills for
Bachelor and I want to talk about that
because wills for Bachelor was trending
after your exit last night on Twitter
yes how does that make you feel we know
you went to paradise what happens in
Paradise find out you're gonna find out
so stay tuned watch that can you tell us
are you single right now I cannot you
can't tell us I'm shocked didn't expect
that answer but bachelor well I guess
we'll have to see what happens in
Paradise but would you be the bachelor
I'm open to any and every opportunity
I'm not gonna say no you know if someone
comes and talks to me that's a
discussion to be had and I'm all for it
I mean it would be amazing because
there's been so much love for you and of
course we still have not had an
african-american bachelor so do you feel
like that's true I mean is I feel like
it's a bit of a double-edged sword I
mean being on The Bachelorette I wanted
to make my family and my friends and
everyone you know proud of me so I feel
like being the first african-american
bachelor it would be a tall task but I
feel like it's something I could handle
everything I've been through in my life
I've handled so far and I think I could
handle that
there was some talk with Rachel Lindsay
season of course she was the first
african-american Bachelorette but about
you know like ratings were down and why
was that and you know what does the
audience have an issue you know why
can't we get behind an african-american
lead I mean so would you feel that
pressure would you take that into
consideration what are your thoughts I
mean it's gonna be pressure regardless
of my skin tone but me personally I just
feel like the world looks a lot
different than what's portrayed on TV
and in the media so I don't I wouldn't
feel a lot of pressure I would feel more
pressure about finding my person I don't
I wouldn't really be worried about how I
look to other people I am Who I am I was
born this way it's never gonna change
and I'm going on with it and Becca
season had a nice you know that was
another thing as the show even said they
were working on getting a more diverse
cast I feel like Becca's season had a
nice group of guys a lot of people
asking including us Sarah who was your
closest friend on the show Sarah I would
say Kristen was one of my closest
friends but I had a lot of close friends
in the house Jason was one of my closest
friends Garret mangueira very very close
Nick
Colton I hate saying like who's my
closest friends cause I was very close a
lot of guys in the house I got along
with at most I'm gonna say everybody not
almost everybody everybody so I'm gonna
say the whole house you got along with
Jordan yes actually
we're fine nice guy I just what about
Chris Chris has one too okay you were
you cracked me up someone let me say
this for the record right now yes
Chris we were all in an environment than
we'd never been in before an intense
emotional environment that is the reason
in Vegas I did not come back at Chris
with hostility
I know it was just kind of a nature of
the beast and I knew he was coming from
a place that was genuine it might have
been a little misguided but it was
genuine and that's why I tried to talk
to him firmly yet I just loved watching
you all season because I felt like you
said so much without saying so much like
you just stand and be like you really
was that important to you to kind of
well I mean maintain decorum absolutely
because I'm in front of someone who can
potentially be my wife and I didn't I
personally never wanted to bring drama
in front of her and I was directly in
front of her and a potentially hostile
situation so the best thing I could do
as leave the situation for a second then
come back and when I came back and he
still didn't want to respect my wishes
that's when I won had to put my foot
down and be like now it's my time was
that situation representative of who
Chris is absolutely well maybe see a
different side of Chris why did you go
on the show in the first place how did
you end up on the Bachelorette I was
recruited off the street by casting
director you know you are love you but
no I was walking back from work back to
work after buying some headphones so
glad I needed headphones and yeah i was
just stopped on the street i was a
little skeptical at first because i'm
very you know you know closed off when
i'm walking in the streets but um no i
talked to the casting director she asked
me if I was single and what I was doing
and I told her I was single and I told I
was going back to work she gave me her
card and I thought it was some kind of
scam and I looked it up and she was good
to go and I talked to my family about it
and they said go for it okay so had you
been single for awhile before that about
a year yeah and you're ready to get
married
yes wills ready you guys okay a lot of
questions coming in for wills cuckoo on
Facebook what a name is asking about
Garrett and yes you just said Garrett
was one of your closest friends and I do
want to talk to you about that then
because Garrett of course has had this
Instagram scandal he liked some very
controversial memes he then released a
statement apologizing for it and as his
close friend I mean have you talked to
him what did you think of that was
spoken of Garrett about the whole
situation all I know is in the house he
was a great guy I feel like he did make
some mistakes I don't agree with the you
know the things that he said or liked or
whatever that is I haven't spoken to him
about it but all I can really base my
opinions on are the interactions I've
had with them and he it was a very sweet
guy genuine guy and yeah I think he just
made some misguided mistakes well what
was the reaction amongst you guys
because I know when you go through this
show the contestants get very close you
look a group text a lot of it I mean
what was the reaction amongst the guys
and I think I think first off is just
support because we don't know the whole
story so I think it's just kind of
support you know we kind of have to
stick together and just really be there
for one another like if it she was on
the other foot I would hope that the
guys would come and support me and try
to see you know what's going on with me
and drying that you know figure things
out so I think when hold gear in news
broke I think it was just first coming
from a place of support and then she
to get more information on it were you
surprised I mean yeah I mean absolutely
I mean when I was in the house with him
he was like I said he's one of my
closest friends we got along great he's
very very he was a big sweetheart you
know we cooked together we you know hung
out together everything he was just a
really great guy so let's see another
yeah it was definitely surprising okay
well um and kuku was also asking who do
you think is better suited for Becca
amongst these top guys now I also want
to get your reaction to Becca saying she
was in love with Blake last night I was
surprised by that how did you guys know
yes she said that she felt the same
about him but she couldn't tell him
that's man so going back looking at it
is this it's a little tough for guys
like me because you can clearly see how
strong some of our relations are son
excuse me so strong some of our
relationships are with other people as
opposed to like me and it's tough to see
I'm not gonna lie but you know she feels
how she feels and if she that's the way
she feels and she wants to say it
without saying it and kudos our bikes a
huge sweetheart sauce yeah it was a
little crazy to me I'm like oh she had
these feelings for Blake at this point
okay so did you guys get that sense like
could you tell that Blake was really
somebody she was really in it was kind
of a running joke and I was from almost
the beginning that Garrett and Blake
were like I said a lot especially since
it's come out he had dated TIA we're
actually gonna we got a tease last night
that we will see Tia again come back and
talk to Becca
what do you think of she's very lovable
and coldness too but what do you think
of his intentions and everything that
people are saying personal I loved
Colton and I love to you I have
expressed that you know their whole
situation I'm kind of a person where you
kind of need to make a decision one way
or the other I don't know the whole
background history on them I just feel
like one way or the other you need to
make a decision if you're gonna be with
somebody be with them if you don't move
on
that's just how I personally feel about
it I don't really like the whole
wishy-washy thing my grandma's are
saying I can't say it on TV but it's you
better or get off the pot and and I mean
that correlates to them it's just you
need to figure it out you need to really
just sit down and so during the season
did you feel like he still had feelings
for Tia absolutely not no I had no idea
he auntie that ever dated
the whole spa date situation I had no
idea until that night so he was really
keeping that under wraps absolutely okay
I also want to talked about another
controversial guy Lincoln has anyone
spoken to him since it came out that he
had been arrested I spoke to him briefly
and I I told him if he needed someone to
talk to I'm here for him he said he'd
reach out to me I haven't heard from him
but do you think or have you gotten an
indication that we'll see him at men
tell all I mean that's a big question I
asked the whoever is you know scheduling
tough because you know he I mean he
really was convicted of this crime but I
mean with likely Garrett he had sent
some very upsetting tweets and he was
still there so I'm interested to see if
we will hear from him or time so many
questions and comments coming in on
Facebook you're a very fine man was she
the best also Veronica well Veronica had
wondered who he thinks the best match
for Becca is now gosh that's a tough
question I would imagine you maybe know
something as you can't tell us who do
you think is the best match for Becca
Veronica wants to know I mean all the
guys left are so different yeah I mean
Jason is just so effervescent and just
carefree and fun here it is
Garrett is just you know laid back but
still goofy and quirky Blake is just a
sweetheart you know he's gonna be there
for you massaging your feet when you're
sick and Colton is just a big goofball
like I feel like you would always be
there with this dog running around the
house with you like I just feel like
they all bring something different to
the table and it just depends on what
that guys really really sees in a future
husband okay I love how you summed each
other my friends amazing Karm on
facebook says that she loves how you've
been handling all this you're so
well-spoken and handsome you will find
your bride no doubt and Nancy says you
are a fine young man full of class with
a great future ahead of you a lot of
support from the ladies I love this so
yeah it wasn't like I said I've just all
of these tweets last night about you
crying about how tough that was for
people to watch
have you had ladies sliding into the DMS
quite there has been an outpouring of
support and love and admiration and I
appreciate every single one of you no
not seriously not gonna lie about a year
ago and some change I don't really know
exactly but I felt very very alone in
this world and just seeing all you guys
reach out to me and show me love and
respect I really really appreciate it
getting a little emotional seriously
really really appreciate it thank you
guys all of you seriously did this show
help you get out of that place
absolutely
Becca mainly helped me get out of that
place and all the guys and all the crew
and producers helped me as well there's
a huge family can you talk about what it
was that had kind of gotten you into
that moment what moment when you said
you felt very alone oh I just you know I
was coming off a hard breakup and I just
didn't really feel wanted by anyone I
kind of had a couple you know grows well
excuse me women I was speaking to and it
just didn't work out and I just started
questioning myself again there's this
tough time why was it Becca or what was
it about this situation that guy you
know honestly the first time like when I
first got up a limo I was incredibly
stressed out I had no idea what I was
getting myself into and you know there's
kind of a space I have to walk before I
get up to Becca and I didn't think I was
going to speak to her until I was
literally in front of her as soon as I
got the car both of my feet weren't even
out of the limo yet she was all right
like hi how are you in talking to me and
from that second I knew everything was
gonna be fine and I was gonna be on for
the ride of my life
is that what this felt like the ride of
your life she made it very very easy to
open up and you know emote and just be
yourself she was amazing Bachelorette I
wouldn't change it for the world were
you in love with her yes I told her that
in Richmond I wasn't yeah sometimes you
know he'd look back and we wonder you're
in this bubble it's this crazy situation
I don't say things unless I'm you know
and like there was a couple moments that
weren't aired but we had a couple
familiar some similarities and like kind
of epiphany moments especially one in
Vegas and from that moment on and I just
knew like I was falling hard for this
girl well I just can't imagine what you
went through cuz you're in love with her
yeah you get sent home yeah you're in
tears and then what you kind of have to
go back and be by yourself for a while
and just go a little bit cleanse a
little bit
hung out with my family a lot that
helped a lot just kind of got my mind
off of it a good place what was it that
helps you get to a good place just kind
of spending more time on myself I just I
feel like I put a lot of time into
relationships and I have put a lot of
time in relationships and I need to
realize that I need to put a lot of time
into myself as well it's kind of the
whole put your breathing mask on before
you help someone else so it's kind of
that I want to do a lot more like
self-care and just helping myself I play
soccer a lot you know I hang out with my
friends a lot I'm a huge uncle like
uncle you know just um cool the year
every year so I just like to hang out
with them and just kind of you know
distressing unplug so in a couple words
how would you describe this experience
wild emotional carefree and hardest
moment well to me being sent home I
didn't really have to
once I was once the process of me
getting sent home was I was just kind of
there and just dealing with my own
emotions internally but in Vegas it was
there was multiple factors and I had to
speak my mind be firm also try to
impress this woman that I'm potentially
willing to you know be engaged to so all
of those different factors all at once
all the cameras were rolling you know
just being quick about it and being
respectful it was very very difficult
anything you wish you'd done differently
I wanted to make lasagna soup and in
Park City Utah
sorry that's soup it's like it's like
deconstructed lasagna you put the cheese
in the bottom and you put the soup on
top and soups hot and the cheese melts
and I wanted to make it for everyone but
we didn't get the ingredients in time
that's a weird thing you regret is that
you didn't do something for everybody
knew that I could he is a great cook I'd
more comments so much sympathy and love
coming through for you just as that the
way that you're talking just has her
shook right now a lot of the ladies
your fashion moments agree you guys God
that plaid suit I was like look at the
confidence that's Cynthia says you are
definitely on the road to recovery
you're not only fine but you are a
gentleman anything that you wish you had
said to Becca but you didn't
that's a good question I don't think so
actually I kind of had a not a really a
game plan but every time because time
with her was very precious so I always
thought about exactly what I wanted to
say like topics I want to say and every
time I got a chance to speak with her I
knew exactly kind of the overlaying you
know categories of what I wanted to talk
to her about and I don't think I regret
anything I don't think I missed out on
anything I told her I was falling all
over there I told her that she made me
believe in love again I told her reasons
why I was falling in love with her like
everything up to that point was
everything that I wanted to tell her so
what's going through your mind when
you're in that limo is that the
realization that you've been broken up
with that this process of exit
[Music]
it was everything only one I mean it was
a long ride I was fortunate enough to be
there as long as I was but yeah it's
leaving my friends leaving the producers
who were like my family and leaving the
crew is like my family I'm going home to
the unknown was kind of difficult the
whole kind of being rude not necessarily
rejected but just not being picked it's
kind of about feeling and just having
that feeling of heartbreak again it was
hard but I just feel like I'm gonna
continue to try to love and heartbreak
is the potential outcome of that you
just got to deal with it I would just
imagine that it's hard especially you
opening up now and saying that you had
been through this time when you felt
very alone but then you find this family
and then you find this woman and then
you're going right back to like were you
scared about getting into that place of
feeling alone again life is absent flows
I mean there's gonna be there's gonna be
moments that are hard and there's gonna
be moments that are great the times that
are great aren't as great if you don't
have the hard time my tattoo is the
reason I got it oh you look for light in
the darkness there's gonna be darkness
in your life a lot of darkness but
there's gonna be a lot of light and if
you stay stubborn enough in the darkness
that lights gonna come eventually so you
just got to be stubborn put your head
down put one foot in front the other and
it'll be okay what's harder the exit
limo ride or the next day when you kind
of wake
and you you realize everything that's
happening I'm gonna say the next day
because I'm obviously kind of a reserved
private person and just going back into
the public and wanting to just curl into
a ball and cry your eyes out and the
airport is kind of difficult and you
know finding from the Bahamas to LA is a
long time and it was just difficult
holding those tears in for that long
yeah that was tough are you by yourself
during that
no absolutely not you know I flew home
with some other people but just being in
public like I personally just don't like
crying in public especially just in it
like no I just don't like that is it
weird for you then that you cried on
national television not at all because
to me it was I mean I knew I was being
filmed but at the same time I did it
like I knew I was being filmed in the
car I knew I was being filmed outside
the car but I was kind of turned my back
was turned I was kind of in my own
environment I didn't really think about
anything else other than my feelings in
that moment it doesn't bother me so have
you spoken to Becca at all since all
this I have not spoken aback of
whatsoever but I know she's I think I
hope she's engaged to one of my closest
friends though I know our paths are
gonna come across again and I hope she's
happy and I'm gonna be happy to see
you're happy and I hope you can be you
know friends well you will I would
imagine see her at men tell all what do
you plan to say to her anything you've
thought about that you want to discuss
hi how you been
you look great I love like you know
she's gonna look great just so many
women again saying they have roses they
will give to you Wells we're gonna wrap
up here but can you tell us any and a
couple words about how paradise went for
you maybe I have one word for you
watch Wow again very very solid future
in politics Susie says it was her loss
you are wonderful if I were 20 years
younger I love that Susie Susie age is
just a number that's a lot of dancing do
you know what you're looking for in a
woman now did this experience help you
figure that out yeah absolutely I mean I
feel like you know even before I met
Becca I kind of
what I wanted I'm you know I want
someone who's not afraid to laugh for
themselves I want someone who's kind of
goofy but can also have a serious
conversation I also want someone who's
kind I know it sounds obvious but I just
want someone who's kind nurturing
because I'm gonna be kind of nurturing
for her and I just want to build
something together and you know have a
great life together so have any
discussions or talks about you being
bachelor happened no comment no comment
it's been thrown out there on Twitter I
think there's anyone I spoken to anyone
about being a nice person oh okay
alright Will's thank you so much for
being here I just can't thank you enough
so excited to have you come in today and
again you guys he really turned it out
everybody makes sure to follow wills on
social media and you guys don't tune
away for too long because literally in
about 15 minutes we're gonna go live
with the lovely Lauren Bushnell and talk
more Bachelorette it's just a
Bachelorette morning here at et so
thanks for watching roses in rows a and
I just want to give a quick thank you to
our crew you guys because our crew works
their butts off yes wills and I are
applauding the crew right now they are
making this Bachelorette morning happen
for all the fans I'm gonna call out
Ricardo rego the arocs hose way
everybody is so amazing so thank you
guys and again everybody tune in in just
a few minutes are going live with Lauren
Bushnell and wills we'll get more from
you at Men's hello Anne done paradise
it's good watch The Bachelorette Mondays
on ABC and bachelor in paradise
premieres very soon this summer thanks
everybody
[Music]
[Music]